Amazon's massive hiring spree is in full
swing it is trying to recruit 50,000 new
employees thousands of job seekers land
up at where's just a day for a chance to
work for the online giant the
seattle-based company held simultaneous
job fairs at twelve locations across the
country many applicants were hired on
the spot engine ideas is that Amazon
warehouse in Kenosha Wisconsin it ran a
good morning good morning if you needed
any confirmation that Amazon is serious
about the stops push just take a look at
the giant sign they've posted on a
tractor trailer outside their Center in
Kenosha we met all sorts of applicants
here from out-of-work lawyers to people
who've been laid off from jobs in retail
many said they think online shopping
will only grow and that means job
security from Baltimore Maryland to
Kenosha Wisconsin to Kent Washington
thousands of people across the country
waited in seemingly never-ending lines
all of them hoping for a spot on the
Amazon team I got laid off because of me
there was no work sandy Martinez isn't
your typical Amazon applicant
I've never ordered anything in like
she's hoping to land one of the 50,000
jobs posted by the online retailer
Amazon wants associates that can sort
pack and ship and we'll pay 1152 15
dollars an hour across the nation Amazon
offered applicants like sandy tours
inside their fast-paced facilities and
no this video is not sped up they got a
look at the jobs they want
and the jobs already replaced by robots
here instead of sappers walking to
shelves
the shelves now come to them ELISA Tran
is an Amazon spokesperson should people
be concerned that if they apply for a
job here that job may disappear No
so automation simply makes our jobs here
more efficient for our associates so we
continue to hire to meet customer demand
thousands were hired on the spot
pending background checks like this
mother and son duo in Romeoville
Illinois it feels great
because I have a PI here many times but
I've got denied but they finally gave me
a chance
Amazon says it wants to add 100,000 jobs
by the middle of next year but as
e-commerce grows traditional
brick-and-mortar stores are suffering in
the last 15 years department stores have
lost nearly half a million jobs flat
Adrianna thanks